software development cycles call for
repeated testing and automating as this
can shorten development life cycles
eliminate the possibility of human error
and automate mundane and monotonous
tasks
more importantly this makes way for
continuous development of a product but
the skills needed to get the right jobs
go beyond just learning to use the tools
organizations need individuals who can
run automated tests on new or existing
software
welcome to simplylearn's automation
testing job guarantee program
if you're looking to start a new career
in automation testing our job guarantee
program is for you
with salaries starting at 4 lakhs per
annum and going up year on year
automation testing offers a great career
opportunity
what makes this program different
this automation testing training program
is designed to provide you with complete
knowledge of software testing
technologies such as selenium test gene
cucumber and docker to help you build a
robust testing framework along with
hands-on training and industry projects
you get trained by top industry experts
and practitioners through live virtual
sessions with plenty of support and
guidance
after completing the course you become
eligible for various roles such as
automation test engineer quality
assurance engineer software test
engineer software development engineer
and more
that's not all
you get access to the best career
mentors and industry leaders for job
placement assistance resume enhancements
interview preparation and one-on-one
mock interviews
enhance your profile become job ready
and get placed at top companies
you can also access this program with
zero cost emis with no hidden fees
at the end of the program you get
industry recognized certificates a
complete automation testing skill set
and a job within six months of
completion
if you don't get placed you get a 100
refund
that's the simply learn job guarantee
promise
join us for the next cohort apply now
[Music]